well gas prices as you know still sky
high across the nation they're
especially high right here in nevada the
secretary of energy jennifer granholm
was in town today touring a new hydrogen
plant so we went christian casares was
there to ask her when this pain at the
pump might finally come to an end well
secretary jennifer granholm tells me
relief is coming americans should expect
those prices at the pump to roll back
very soon as the biden administration
continues to work hard to stabilize the
market
so the transportation of the fuel is
expensive that is what secretary of
energy jennifer granholm says is one
reason that is keeping nevada gas prices
high
an average of 5 dollars and 15 cents is
what aaa says southern nevada residents
are paying for a gallon of regular gas
you have
a series of gas taxes and second is that
you're not adjacent to a refinery
grant home says overall those soaring
prices are due to vladimir putin and his
attack on ukraine which pulled russian
oil off the market she says the u.s and
canada pulling back on the use of oil to
avoid financing the attacks that means
supply is less and costs go up she says
president biden is also using our own
supplies he's also released the biggest
tool that we have which is 180 million
barrels from our strategic petroleum
reserve that's a million barrels a day
for the next six months while our oil
and gas companies start ranking you know
cranking up their engines but it's
unclear how much those prices will drop
as millions of drivers get ready to hit
the road during the summer season grand
home reiterates the importance of clean
energy and becoming self-sufficient the
best solution to wean us off of fossil
fuels is to do things like what we're
seeing here at air lockheed to use
hydrogen to be able to have clean
transportation to use electricity
through batteries to electrify our
vehicles
well another thing the secretary says is
moving the country in that clean energy
direction is president biden's approval
for more ethanol to be blended into
gasoline so there's less resilience on
crude oil and more resilience on ethanol
christian casa is live local now